look at him he just wizarded he is
wizarded all over look at this guy's
sweet invisible car
s
so this is all practical effects here
there's some really fun magic tricks
going on it's just probably a big dude
no but he's yeah
huge man how big of a dude did they get
the world's biggest dude
big thanks to epidemic sound for
sponsoring this video stick around to
the end to see how you can get a free
30-day trial
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode skip skip artist react today
we're going to be looking at something
skip all right here we go let's do it
all right let's jump into it
okay there's this clip that's been
around for like a year now and I've seen
it a few times but it just came back up
on our subreddit and I was like hey it's
about time we finally talk about it
because it's really fun to watch
[Music]
look at this guy's sweet invisible car
oh he's got a mirror there can't
possibly be fake I love how he's got the
comments antagonizing him saying it's
insane every time he's like do it with
the TV on check it out dude the TV's
playing and not in reverse so how could
he be moving in Reverse it's almost like
you can't reverse TV footage
[Music]
it's like it's
the sun okay he's gonna do some donuts
it's pretty clear right it's reverse
footage he's sliding in and just doing
the miming and choreography like
flawlessly but if you're to play this
backwards because it's already backwards
that's what would actually be filmed
also it helps that he doesn't have any
hair to betray the fact that the footage
is backwards based on the name of the
tick tock account he does yoga and he
has really good balance so he can you
know when you sit down you kind of fall
into the last part he's good enough at
yoga we can like curl up and act like
he's sitting down and like keep his
balance without falling down yeah it's
like he's just a really good physical
like performer when it comes to like
understanding how to change your body's
movement it's honestly the most
impressive part of all of this he's
probably just actually pushing us that's
how I thought he was doing it but like
he's got some slippery floors dude yeah
yeah he just done a great job it's it's
really funny I mean obviously he's just
having fun with it like I'm sure some
people are like how did he do this and
clearly now you know but I'm sure most
people are just like haha this is fun
it's reverse footage
without it what am I to be
Lord of the Rings rings of power rings
of power I haven't started watching the
show yet but I am very excited to do so
Sam you start watching it though right
yeah I've only gotten two episodes in
but it's it is just great also what is
it like ilm and waita and like d-neg and
like basically every VFX house in the
world contributed to this which is
insane probably because they had that
many shots yeah there's like 10 000 VFX
shots in this
1 500 VFX artists it was like 20 VFX
Studios this is like the biggest thing
ever dude I mean freaking in-game had
like 3 000 VFX shots and that's a two
and a half hour movie
so this is bigger than that I just
wanted to look at the environment shots
there's just so many gorgeous
environments in this piece it's worth it
let's just like just
just Glimpse at this just like bask in
the glory
look at that every guy on I love the
Alvin Smith's dude the realm of the
Elven Smith I want to go to the realm of
the Elven Smiths I don't even know how
to like talk about that stuff because
it's so like Flawless you just look at
it you're like yeah you did it so the
one thing I don't know about yet in this
show because there's not really much
released when it comes to like the VFX
breakdowns yeah but like obviously in
the first Lord of the Rings trilogy
they're using bigatures a ton yeah
whereas in this series I think they may
have forgotten those
I mean that foreground stuff there looks
real all those plants that rock stuff
there that looks real but then of course
you get to the CGI water beyond that
yeah mostly just for logistical reasons
it's like you can't really just have a
waterfall on your set but it looks
pretty good like even these people in
the distance look incredibly convincing
and you look at that and like it kind of
looks like a set and not like a just a
CG background extras anyways yeah so
it's gorgeous it's like an incredibly
gorgeous show like every landscape all
right what is like one of the most
iconic effects from Lord of the Rings
I'd say like the forced perspective
moving camera shots exactly the first
perspective stuff was some of the most
magical effects in the original Lord of
the Rings because it was like in camera
but they were effect shots and they sold
the idea that Gandalf is like three
times larger than Frodo exactly so
there's tiny people in this series as
well and there's also big people
whoa that's cool that's pretty sweet
yeah so really cool stuff but he's he's
normal size are you sure he's not a
wizard I'm pretty sure he's a wizard
look at him he just wizarded he is
wizarded all over so there's like two
excellent shots well bat being one of
them wait that looks like just a basic
Force perspective but they're on the
same plane but were they I don't know if
they really were oh yeah you can see
their feet and the contact because when
you're doing forced perspective you have
to hide the fact that they're at
different distances from the camera and
when it's very clear that they're on the
same plane it introduces complications
we did a forced perspective we've done a
lot of force respective shots we have a
really silly one in our like old video
powered up yeah powered up Master Chief
eats a Mario mushroom and so it gets all
huge and so we just put the camera low
on the ground and had our Mario played
by Benji go away in the distance and had
Jake as Master Chief way in the
foreground yeah we just had him kind of
sync up their moves but in that
situation you had the camera close to
the ground specifically to hide the
distance between them so that the ground
pretty much looked flat yep in relation
to the camera so so if they film this
shot for real he would have to be on
some sort of like elevated platform
closer to camera and they're using his
cloak to kind of hide the edges of it so
I can kind of see on the left side of
his cloak how it goes down and right
behind it is the ground that would be
how they would do in Lord of the Rings
it's probably how they did that here
right if this is all in camera it's also
a possibility they just filmed them and
cut her out and Shrink her down yeah or
enlarged him I think it'd be easier to
make him bigger you're probably right
because actually Sam brings up an
interesting point contact Shadows on the
ground so Shadows don't just make things
darker there's a reflection of the sky
on those leaves and twigs on the bottom
left see how they're bright they're
reflecting the sky and you'll notice you
don't have those spikes of highlights
below her so when they get cast in
Shadow they don't get darker the
reflection itself needs to disappear
whereas we look at the ground around him
there's a little more of a sense of
those Reflections being on the leaves
especially that little like Nook
underneath his fabric I get the
impression that he was scaled up or at
least his contact with the ground was
done by hand with VFX whereas she is
completely natural I don't know I'm not
saying what you're seeing if I was doing
the shot and I was enlarging him I would
also enlarge the ground
too he had
he had wet with the fair so that you can
easily cut that out but anything below
that the ground there probably got
scaled up with his cloak because why
wouldn't you you've got the built-in
subject that's a great way to actually
preserve the contact Shadows but here's
a little thing about doing an effect
like this that catches a lot of people
by surprise and they do it for the first
time generally when you film something
you have a little bit of noise and Grain
in your shot so when you cut something
out like this guy and you scale him up
you also scale up all the noise and
grain meaning you can really tell if you
zoom in on the elements which one's been
scaled up or down because you got this
fine detail that's now something bigger
one side of the shot but how do you fix
that Nico well there's a couple ways to
fix it one is you really have to go out
of your way to shoot without noise on
set which means a lot of light taking
the ISO on your camera and dropping it
really low you can also denoise it and
then the second step is to go in and put
a uniform version of noise on the entire
shot or at least on your comp subjects
and have that noise match everything
else it's the subtle thing that a lot of
people miss and it's one of those things
that informs like the subconscious part
of your brain that something's off but
you're not realizing that you're just
seeing these little specks of different
sizes showing up so there's another
great shot with actual like 3D camera
moves that's towards the end of this
sequence
oh
ah they almost look the same size but
they're not they're not no wait a minute
they're not the same size she not there
the whole time how could she be not
there but look at how her hair goes
against the sky and you can see like the
halation on her yeah the sky is not real
there he's comped he's calmed he's comp
he's comp are you kidding me dragon is
like sloppy blanket around like a zombie
blanket
look at his foot and you can see like
the Twigs perfectly dragging we don't
see her feet though we don't see her
feet she could be calmed I have a
feeling
and it's a motion control thing if I was
doing this
with a slightly enlarged camera move you
know it's like you do the camera move
initially with him and then you take
that you enlarge everything do the same
camera motion on her on a different set
and probably just entirely remove her
and put her into that the reason why I'm
saying that is because we never want to
see her feet specifically her feet
interacting with the ground there it
could be a motion control thing with her
being calmed you're right but you look
at it you're like ah darn it you you
tricked me yeah I mean it's almost
impossible to see that they're stumped
take a look at that little out of focus
splotch of sky where it's white in the
center then as it gets towards the edges
of the blur where like the trees are in
front it turns blue because when
something goes out of focus and there's
another thing in front of it's out of
focus it's kind of it's like having
sunglasses on that little Edge there it
brings the exposure down so the camera
sees the sky it's basically white
because the sky is so hot and then as
those blurry things in the foreground
cover it up it doesn't bring the white
down to gray it brings exposure down and
of course the sky is blue so you see
blue and that's why you get that white
to Blue roll off so looking at the other
shots where the characters are standing
up and the sky is behind their hair what
you need to look for is this
intense blue that appears and I see it
on her hair there we go they're starting
to get it yeah starting to get that blue
yeah it's like the blue edging and
that's something that you can get in
compositing when you really work
carefully with your edges and your light
but for the most part I don't see
composing do that correctly so if she is
composited and they did an amazing job
they could have shot that sequence on
the volume as well true the volume would
give you that effect still doesn't solve
why he's big no you're right uh we
forgot we gotta remember what our boy
Peter did back in the day not Peter R
Peter but Peter the the world's Peter
Peter Jackson Peter the Jackson had
actors that were different sizes when he
didn't show their face we can't see the
Wizard's face in this shot it's just
probably a big dude no but he's talking
huge man how big of a dude did they get
the world's biggest dude because the
size from his knee to his ankle is
straight up like bigger than her torso
that hand yeah look at that he has a
child's hand it's just a child's hand
right it's an innocent child's hand see
look at that I'm getting the vibe that
each shot they're using a slightly
different technique so that way it keeps
fooling you you know like there yeah we
definitely he's hiding they're hiding
the face there because they interacted
do we see him touching the ground yeah
yes but he's touching the ground this
might be a practical effect we're
looking at right here I think you're
right this might be a big dude here and
on a shot by shot basis they're
replacing his head or face yeah the
people who worked on the show are gonna
be like what that's the only thing you
looked at from our Halls like show this
is whether or not like this dude is real
or not I think it's safe to say we will
be looking at rings of power again once
we actually like finish yeah on the show
so make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss it this is gonna be awesome in fact
you know what hopefully we can get
someone who worked on this on the show
[Music]
[Laughter]
11 by ABC it went for like seven seasons
or whatever this has less to do with the
quality of the effects and more of the
quality of the editing
let's watch
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa this editing doesn't feel like a
Band-Aid at all ambitious though doing
the screen screen fight yeah for a TV
show but they just gave up completely on
like the choreography I mean that was a
pretty sick wire stunt there though oh
that's cool that's cool up and over
landed
I'm sleeping just kidding
foreign
Crash Pad yep it's like that bouncy
ground
[Laughter]
11 years ago and it's a TV show budget
so I'm not really like harshly
critiquing the quality of the effects
here there's only so much you can do and
they were ambitious about it but what
kills me is the editing the rate of
editing makes it so that there's so many
VFX shots so I think what ended up
happening is that they had all these
different VFX shots that were longer and
they had it edit it in and someone
decided it wasn't working and to go back
and re-edit it all if we're to actually
talk about the effects here what are we
looking at so we're looking at a green
screen stage with two actors fighting on
it and that requires not only replacing
the background but replacing the ground
as well and so everything we're seeing
has to be recreated to match the
lighting on them and I'd say that like
overall it's not too bad yeah the
lighting's not too bad but the big issue
I'm noticing is that when you get motion
blur on a green screen the motion blur
you're seeing the green screen behind it
so oftentimes it gets keyed out and you
end up when with somebody moving they
get really skinny and that guy gets yeah
when that guy gets lifted over you'll
notice like all his limbs get really
skinny and it's easily fixed just by
shooting on a higher shutter speed when
you're on your green screen yeah so you
can probably guess the shutter speed you
want to film at you know you can go like
all right hi what's high one over 240
one over 500 one over a thousand like
the easiest way to do it is just do a
test it's like if you're unsure just
film it quick hit playback I mean if
you're on a union set hire a guy to play
the video back for you you know but
either way you know that's that's the
simple process you can really especially
see the motion blur issue when that guy
is swinging his weird spear around or
the motion blur eats in so far to the
stick that when you pull the key the
stick just completely disappears with
motion blur and a dark stick moving fast
to be fair it does also just disappear
on regular footage too yeah but it
leaves a smear it doesn't just
completely disappear it does depend on
how exposed this yeah if it's decent
exposure it should
if it's dark exposure like it kind of
looks here it's not going to expose as
well ah TV these days TV's all like high
budget we can't dunk on sick effects and
TVs yeah I mean watching the best show
in the world compared to this you know
he was watching a TV show at 500 million
dollars for a budget versus the show
that probably had like uh
let's take it back to 1988 let's blob it
up guys this has been a great
recommendation uh Hey if you got more
recommendations please leave a comment
down below we'd love to read them gives
us ideas I wasn't alive back then
oh
buddy
uh-oh screaming what's going on
[Music]
whoa oh no this is gonna be bad
it's gonna be bad oh this is gonna be
bad oh
my God oh my God all right wow
oh I love this stuff it's so fun this
came out in 1988 this was before
computers were invented yeah so this is
all practical effects here there's some
really fun magic tricks going on so you
got a Blog right how do you direct a
blob how do you activate a blob to give
to give you some acting how do you have
it move so here's what they came up with
here's how they were able to make the
blob do things right like you see it
going up the wall you see it falling
from the ceiling you see it dragging
over his face they basically made a
quilt out of silk they sewed this silk
blanket together making little pockets
like little raviolis in it this quilt
and they filled it with food gel and
then like the food gel would like seep
out of the threads of silk and so you'd
end up with this big like a gooey
blanket that had blobs coming out of it
and each blanket it would weigh like 200
pounds oh my God this is all just like
water gel yeah and they'd use that they
could use like sticks they'd put on
mittens that were blob mittens so they
could like move it and you couldn't see
people's hands so the scenes where he's
like getting digested they actually have
this big fiberglass thing that he's
sitting in and they're pulling like a
blob blanket over his face like uh and
actually have like another one that
they're like pulling in an opposite
direction and one's blue and one's red
so as they interact they make different
purple streaks that kind of come and go
like bring things to life that's really
clever yeah because yeah it's like At
first I didn't even think of that I was
like wow this is just some like
what is like jello or gak or whatever
that you know remember yeah yeah you
know what I'm saying silly putty oh like
that world of like goopy toys but yeah
you can't control that you know like how
do you make it move and the silk sheet
that's kind of like the key because now
it's like solid and if you pull on it
everything comes with it it doesn't just
like rip off and fall apart and this is
just a puppet the guy is a miniature the
guy is a miniature that's a miniature so
what else would have to be a miniature
if he was a miniature
her yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
it would have to be miniature dolls man
that's a 100 dolls in this shot wait
what yep the entire scene that entire
shot is all miniature would you explain
why the globe is gigantic in the
background
s
yeah
okay I'm kind of seeing it now more and
more like her motion is a little I don't
know if stiff is the right word for it
but like there's not much Dynamic
movement to her other than like she kind
of leans down a little bit also the
scale of her hair strands are larger
here yeah it's really well done I mean
like I couldn't have told I know like
that's some amazing puppetry so they
only did this shot miniature because
they wanted that effect of the mouth and
like him getting pulled into it right so
they they couldn't do that with the real
actor that he obviously his mouth
doesn't open that big but I love this he
looked closely at the wrist you can see
the actual Arm coming up from the floor
because they're using a real hand you
can see the where the floor comes up a
little bit oh yeah so it's just
somebody's arm coming up through the
floor and you can see the wrist turn and
go down into the floor and they've just
attached a prosthetic to it with makeup
that's crazy building for that shot yeah
like every shot in this sequence is like
its own unique challenge thing about
these films is that all the Practical
effects required so much planning it's
like every time you get one it's it's
just like it hits so hard like the whole
scene's been built for that one shot
that one insert that one thing that
happens like they're never unimportant
or like unplanned or just casual hey son
of a dungeon just popping off over on
quarterdigital.com heck we even got the
whole season two of crew cuts that just
fidalized finalized finale vanillas yeah
look quarterdigital.com it's our website
it gives us independence from the
YouTube ecosystem so we can make stuff
just for you without worrying about
algorithms and it helps us make cool
things plus there's no ads it's 3.99 a
month which is pretty inexpensive All
Things Considered if you want it you
know where to find it quarterdigital.com
check it out hey everyone it's me Nick
but today you can call me epidemic
because I'm here to talk to you about
today's sponsor epidemic sound what is
epidemic sound well it's a One-Stop shop
for creators to find music and sound
effects and Anything Audio related that
you need to pull off your Creative
Vision so it's really cool that epidemic
wanted to sponsor this video because we
actually have been using epidemic here
at Corridor for years it's our main
source of audio and if searching all of
epidemics vast Sound Library is a little
bit overwhelming well they have this new
feature where they actually serve you a
playlist of personalized recommendations
that are tailor-made for your YouTube
channel based on your past download
history you can search different genres
different styles of music and then they
have some really cool search functions
which let you kind of narrow down every
little aspect of what you're looking for
to help you find exactly what you need
as someone who uses epidemic I know
sometimes I'll find a track I really
like and I'll be like I want more tracks
like this but I don't know the keywords
the search I don't know exactly like
what what genre is it epidemic has a
great solution to that they actually
have a fine similar button that uses all
the different filters that they've used
on the back end to give you a bunch of
similar tracks that match the vibe of a
track that you like for us you know a
lot of times we do need did multiple
pieces of music in one kind of genre and
that button makes things very easy for
us so if you want to elevate your
post-production experience and you're
interested in epidemic sound click the
link Down Below in the description get a
free trial of epidemic it lasts 30 days
and they even got you covered for
anything you create in that time period
honestly we use it every single day here
at Corridor thanks again to epidemic for
sponsoring this video let's get back to
the effects artist react
I mean hey that was a fun one I think
more than anything filming this episode
convinced me that I really gotta start
watching rings of power I'm very excited
for it already but now I gotta watch
yeah just it's chill it's a chill show
is it a little slow yeah it's plot heavy
and a little confusing yeah who cares
get over it it's sweet
anyways this is super enjoyable thank
you so much for watching